[Music]
let's roll out to roll out to Columbus
Ohio and talk to the great Sarah with an
H what's up
Sarah hi Dr John how are you we're
partying what are you up to oh sitting
in a closet hiding for my
children I may have done that too
recently oh it's so it's so like quiet
and dark in there it's nice it's nice so
nice all right so what's up besides the
fact that you're hiding from your
children in a closet so my question is
how can I learn to be more vulnerable
with my husband after months of
emotional
abuse not very
easily uh no it's not very easy um I can
give you a little bit of backgound yeah
tell me about the emotional
abuse so my husband and I we've been
fighting on and off really non-stop
since February about what um anything
and everything um it seems like anything
can become an issue um just to give you
like an example um there was
a work get together for him um where
originally he thought it was going to be
like a spouse get together and then it
wasn't um and I told him you know still
go like you should go to your work thing
and then he was convinced oh you must be
angry because now you can't go
um and I was like well I'm disappointed
it would have been fun but it's fine you
go it's fine and um long story short it
up blowing up into some huge big thing
where he says that I'm lying to him even
though I'm not and somehow it blew up to
even he called his parents over they
entered the fight um this was like way
long ago back in April he called his
mommy yes he did and his
daddy my good gosh um and then I was
ganged up on by the three of them um it
included his mom like aggressively
grabbing me and his dad screaming inches
from my face um Sarah
Sarah it's been
bad hey this isn't
okay I know I think you know that
intellectually I don't think you've
allowed yourself to know that what this
really means you can't be a part of
this yeah um well we did set up
boundaries with his parents eventually
um they can never come into your house
again until they show up at your front
door both on one knee saying I'm so
sorry forgive us for belittling you and
abusing you and acting like children
period yeah the uh the best apology that
I've gotten from his dad was uh me
requesting an apology and him saying his
dad was saying oh well I don't remember
it I don't remember it and I said well
that's not an apology and he said fine
I'm sorry and like yelled at me again
what a coward what a
coward what a spineless spineless
spineless man wow very much so and your
husband is he defending you um
eventually he did um that's kind of one
of the things that I struggled with is
sometimes when you know his parents
haven't been coming around cuz like I
said that was back in April um and I
have insecurities like are you angry
with me that your parents aren't coming
around because it used to be it was like
a weekly thing coming over all the time
and then you know he just kind of shuts
down when we talk about his parents and
I'm like well I don't want you to hate
me like I still want you to have a
relationship but they need to treat me
well and he just is like I just don't
want to talk about it I just don't want
to talk about it and I'm like that's
really invalidating to me well it's not
invalidating I mean that sounds kind of
like like I don't know that sounds like
uh 21st century blog language like I
it's it's bigger than that he got his
cowardice from his
dad yeah because may be super clear I
love my mom and dad to the moon and back
they're
amazing and if my father inches from my
wife's face and was
screaming
baby yeah he uh sat in a chair and
watched it all happen
right my mom I'm just I'm I'm almost
borderline laughing if it wasn't so
heartbreaking like spr a picture my mom
grabbing my
wife well and it was after I had just um
expressed I forget how it even came up
one of the issues of that we have had is
um me not wanting physical intimacy um
and somehow that came up in it and I was
saying you know the reason why I don't
always want it is because I've been a
victim of sexual abuse and right after I
say that is when his mom grabs me and
I'm like what did I just say what did
she grab you what was she trying to was
she reaching to give you a hug no she
claimed that she grabbed my arm because
I was like three feet from her and I was
talking with my hands and she said she
was afraid I was going to hit her so she
very aggressively grabbed my arm and I
mean I didn't raise my hand or anything
I was just like moving whole thing
should have been set up so this sounds
like a
mess so you're ask me your original
question again because I don't think
it's the right question but ask me again
how can I learn to be more vulnerable
with my husband after months of
emotional
abuse um we've been going to well we
we've been going to therapy um and then
it I mean even more forms of emotional
abuse have come out of it um him using
therapy against me like uh you know
talking calmly to each other is a thing
that we've been working on and Hell come
to me and ask me like the other day I
had a complete day off the kids went to
the sitter um so I was home alone ran
errands did some laundry things like
that well there were still dishes in the
sink so he comes home and he asks me um
I need to ask you something calmly can
you promise not to get mad and I said
okay and he asked me what did you do all
day oh God this guy sucks man hey will
you have him call
me love to hear that he actually listens
to your show so um he can't listen to my
show because he would well I mean I
guess he can't he can do whatever he
wants
but he does he does um okay here's the
deal he's not on the phone and your
in-laws are not on the phone you are and
so can we have some like hard honest
truthful conversation that you're not
going to feel like I'm invalidating you
I'm sitting right here with you but I
want to just tell the truth yes okay
truth number
one if you desire closeness with your
husband and you desire intimacy yet you
are your body is paralyzed from
historical sexual
abuse it becomes your adventure
to seek
healing is that fair yeah okay if your
husband calls his mommy and
daddy you knew that that wasn't going to
end
well and so at some level there's a
responsibility that you have to get you
and your children and put them in a car
and leave and go get a hotel room is
that fair yeah at some level and and you
and I could probably pulled a string all
the way back you've internalized that
this is what your life is
worth this is just part of being
Sarah taking this crap from people and
you've probably taken it from people
your whole
life that's very accurate and so the the
path forward is not hoping that the
people that you your body continues to
invite into your life right and you've
heard this saying that you marry your un
unfinished
business if somebody constantly um was
putting demands on you that were
unreasonable and then holding you
accountable and being um abusive in some
shape form or fashion because you didn't
meet these obnoxious standards in a
weird way your body's going to find
somebody to marry who's just like that
because your body wants to fix that
because it constantly is asking what did
I do wrong what did I do wrong why am I
so
unlovable and the only way out of that
cycle is not to meet the needs because
if you had cleaned the sink your husband
would have asked you something else
about what you didn't do right you've
had a whole day off and we can't just
you won't play dress up with me and have
crazy sex night he would have the the
The Benchmark keeps moving right yeah
and so the only path out is for you to
go seek healing for
Sarah so that you can stand up on two
feet and knowingly look in the mirror
and say I'm worth more than this period
I will not be part of a
marriage where my husband outsources a
disagreement to his mommy and
daddy and one of his parents puts their
hands on me in an act of aggression and
the other parent screams in my
face in my home Sarah it's your home
too right oh believe me I screamed that
back okay well that doesn't help either
right that doesn't help didn't but but
they're not welcome there yeah and the
fact that your husband won't talk to
you is a way that he is still owning
power over
you you quote unquote one because Mom
and Dad don't get to come around anymore
so the way he's going to get power back
is by he he used to get power by puffing
his chest up and when he needed backup
he called Mommy and Daddy you took that
away good for you
you put a firm boundary good for
you and so now he's going to grab Power
by grabbing the rope and swimming
underwater he's still going to drag the
boat around with I don't want to talk
about it it's too
hard right yeah yeah and now he used to
have power by being loud and abusive and
um pretty ugly and now he's got power by
woe is me and guilt and sadness and oh
my
gosh and that's the big thing I keep
telling him I'm like clear if that was
the household that he grew up in and
that's where he learned things then I
keep telling him you know you need to go
to therapy yeah when you do that he has
to wall up on you because his mom and
dad have been beating him up his whole
life yeah and he married his unfinished
business
too yeah right and so this is
uncomfortable to say out loud but you
could probably
see Shadows of yourself in them
Fair yeah sucks doesn't it so mean it's
so mean to say but his body's trying to
figure out why did my dad scream in my
face my whole
childhood why was my mom would she do
things and then blame me for
them and then here he's got a wife
standing toe-to-toe with him screaming
this is my house too and he's like ah
there it
is but how do I like do I give him time
to you walk
away and you tell them I'm worth having
a conversation with you that is not
belittling and it's not abusive and it's
not screaming and so when you scream you
are asking me to
leave yeah when you um and it may be
let's be honest it may be that um you
know the great beray Brown says whatever
you go looking for in the world you're
sure to find it may be that he got home
and was like hey what'd you do
today and you were so so highly attuned
to him asking in a way like asking a
question that you immediately went to oh
my God right maybe maybe not Maybe not
maybe he came in it was a total
jerk I think it's the ladder okay right
but that's where we have a disagreement
but here's the deal yeah
like you haven't called it but you're
done and kind of you're done done with
what was how about that you're done with
the marriage that you
had I don't know that you're done with
would you build something new if he was
into I want to I know and that's the big
struggle is like he had his very first
individual therapy appointment um and I
he's been very kind very loving like the
past week so I really want to believe
that
he's going to
it's not it's not how it goes you can't
pick up a basketball for the first time
and start shooting free throws and be
like I really want to be the best free
throw shooter in the world it's going to
take years of practicing every
day yeah and so you had a good first
week that's
awesome that's a huge
win it's a huge win he's having to
completely change his nervous system as
are
you yeah y'all are both having to learn
completely new skills and how to
interact with people because your
interactions with people who are
supposed to love you were hell and so
were
his and so we're not like I just want to
go all in we are but we're going all in
by practicing like crazy and we're going
to celebrate the good moments and we're
going to call out the b the rough
moments the tough
ones yeah so when you first called and I
said how do you rebuild
trust takes a long
time it's
hard it's very hard and I I want to be
the wife that he wants and needs cuz
that's all he keeps telling me you know
his love language is aect physical
affection and I want
to I really want to be able to give it
to him but I just especially with my
history it's it's so hard it's so hard
so two things number one I think history
is a part of it but I think the bigger
part of it is you have to be honest
about your lack of attraction to a man
that sat by and watched his parents come
after
you it's easier to point back to
historical trauma than it is to look at
the man that you married right across
from you that you've got kids together
with and say you were such a coward you
let me take it on my
own that's harder to deal with I think
because there's trauma counseling
there's processes there's plans for how
to work through historical trauma they
suck I've been there I've had my own
they're awful but man I'm on the other
side of it and it's it's
amazing yeah it's hard to to look at
that Dragon though in the bed next to
you and say I'm not attracted to
you because you're a child you're a
coward
yeah and he can say all day long been
too scared to I
know I know it's
hard but I I I think
it's because you see how y'all are in
this this this and I just call it the
dance I wish I had a better language
from it I I took that from Estep prell
there was just a dance it was just a
dance and a dance in a dance and the
dance is I would be braver if you slept
with me more and I would be able to
stand taller if you would say you're
proud of me and you respected me and you
just surprised me by taking your shirt
off the middle of the day like I I want
all these things and you say I may want
to take my shirt off if you weren't such
a coward and you were more brave and you
see how and you just end up in this
merry-go round where you can never catch
each
other yeah and both of you have to say
hey what we're doing is not
working and that means you have to be
very clear about what you need and
that's hard because he might look at you
and say I'm not doing
that and vice
versa but I think him continuing to
blame his
parents you continuing to blame the past
both of those those blames have have
validity they're both real they're super
real but the main issue is he's looking
at you and saying I need something from
you that you're unwilling to give me and
you're looking at him saying I need you
to be something that you're unwilling to
be and that's an ugly hard truth but we
got to start
there yeah is that
fair yeah if I asked you just to Rattle
off a list of five or 10
things that make it very hard to desire
him could you do
that yeah
yeah have you all talked about that in
couples
therapy yeah I've talked about how I I
want to feel safe with him I want to
feel yeah but that's all that's all like
super big lofty counseling
language I just want to feel safe with
you what does that mean that means when
you walk in the door you put your phone
in your bag and you don't take it out
and you look me in the eye and you hug
me like you see what I'm saying like
there's a level of clarity because his
picture of what safe
means I'll just say it in my house what
safety meant for me was that I'm gone
all the time and that I make as much
money as I possibly
can that's how I thought my wife wanted
to feel
safe okay and it wasn't until we were on
the brink that she said safety means
walk in the door put your phone away
don't get your laptop out and just let
me know that I have value to you and I
was like oh crap I don't know how to do
that so I had to learn a new set of
skills real quick
yeah but when you're in counseling and
you just have that that lofty language
you see what I'm saying like I just want
to feel desired no what does that mean
you see what I'm saying yeah I mean I've
told him you know I don't want you to
yell at me don't yell at the kids um
don't slam doors in Anger don't Punch
walls so I want you to flip it around I
want you to flip it around I want you to
take
ownership if you raise your voice I am
leaving if you punch a wall in this home
I call the police every single
time this is not about what he's doing
this is about what you're GNA
do yeah do you see what I'm
saying
yeah he's a grown man acting like a
toddler I don't care who you are you
don't punch holes through a wall with
your wife and your kids there you don't
right and if it happens that one time
you go do you go to hell and back to
make sure it never happens
again yeah but also was he a guy that
was shamed so bad he can't even see
straight by those two parents of his he
was yeah very um very strict religious
household um pulled out
of uh you know pulled out of sex class
in public schools because or sex ed
because they didn't want him teaching
the wrong thing and so he's got that
he's got that that nuclear reactor of
Rage in that ball right beneath his
chest right beneath his rib
cage and it's pulsing and
pulsing and he looked at you in the eye
and said I
do and he made babies with you that is
his
job you can't make that nuclear reactor
go away no matter what you do no matter
how much sex you give him no matter how
clean your house is you can't make that
go away his kids aren't going to be able
to score enough soccer goals his kids
aren't going to be able to get enough
Straight A's for that nuclear reactor to
go away he has to go deal with
that and I know this because I
did he's got to go deal with
it and there's something magic about a
husband who has dealt with that inner
rage said out loud in front of other
people whether a therapist whether a
couple of friends whether a men's group
whether a minister what I don't care but
somebody who's going to give you good
counsel and wisdom and listen to
you there's something about a husband
coming back into their home with that
nuclear reactor disassembled and off and
the whole house goes oh that guy's safe
cuz he's under
control he can handle business if things
get sideways but they're not sideways
here because this home is warm and then
suddenly weirdly you're attracted to him
again it's a vicious vicious cycle that
at the end of the day you've got to take
ownership of and say I can't make you
not hit the hole in the wall but I will
leave you because me and my kids safety
are worth more than
that I can't make you be disgusted by
your parents they're not welcoming my
home because they put their hands on me
and they're too cowardly to say they're
sorry I think it's time for y'all to sit
down in front of a counselor together a
neutral third
party and stop using counselor language
and be very specific and clear I need
this and I need this and I need this
this is not you have to and you have to
this is this is what I
need
and he gets to do the same and then
you'll have to make a hard challenging
grown-up decision by looking at each
other and say I'm willing to commit to
trying to make that happen I'm going to
practice it over time are you still
in that's where y'all are the scary
scary moment in your marriage I do
1,000% think y'all can turn the corner
I've just seen it happen too often I
think you
can but I think you've got to be very
very real you have to choose reality in
a stark way right now
and youall proven to yourself that yall
don't have the skills to do it together
so you need to get some on your own so
you need to get somebody else to
mediate tough season call anytime
anytime and if your husband wants to
call and provide the other side of the
story which there always is one I'd love
to hear it I'd love to hear
it